it's been a long day george lowe where
he loved to be at the heart of the party
i nappa cyprus a few hours later he was
dead he had a big circle of friends
everybody just loved him i think because
he was such a character that
you couldn't help but love him
that night the regular bar crawl ended
in horror in a knife attack
george an estate agent was stabbed to
death his best friend ben barker was
badly injured but survived
had
george been involved in any kind of
trouble like this before no never he
wasn't
he wasn't he would stick up for himself
but he wasn't a troublemaker no
two suspects are still on the run from
cyprus police
bulgarian sali ahmet wanted for murder
and attempted murder
and a turk mehmet akpana the same
allegations
ahmet has been seen in turkey
it's believed akpana is there too both
protected by the absence of diplomatic
relations between turkey and cyprus i
was right
turkey to hand them over
and for them to face
um trial in
southern cyprus
and
and
they'll found guilty
to serve prison time
in instagram messages apparently from
mehmet akpana the suspect threatened
survivor ben barker then taunts him
ben tells akpanah he knows he wasn't the
killer
sally ahmed was
but akpana does admit he stabbed ben
i think what um aphanae is trying to do
is to
just push all the blame onto ahmed they
can
say or they like
who done it and who didn't do it but
it's not
unless they're there standing in a cult
yeah
where we
we need them to be
today members of george's family will
meet foreign office officials for an
update on the case they hope cyprus
police will dial into the meeting
when we went to see george in the
military
we
promised him we'd do all we could
and we won't go back on that
the foreign office said it continued to
support george's family and was in
contact with cyprus
authorities martin brunt sky news kent